thank you
it is
right
all right well
welcome everyone
[Music]
well let me try that again it's great to
see the auditorium full
foreign's annual Christmas lecture now
reinstated post pandemic
uh I don't want to take any time away
from Don so I'm not going to
I'll just simply mention I came here in
the 1970s as a transfer student from the
great state of Wisconsin I took a course
from Don and every time there was room
in the class people would come rushing
in and fill it because he was so such a
wonderful teacher and such an
inspiration to so many so you all know
Don for something I'm glad that you're
here I think I'll just sit down and let
him begin
science department and so I want to
thank thank John for well for his uh
great his Service as chair so uh now I
started this uh
well this is the 26th annual
Christmas lecture and and and for for 20
years we call it the Christmas tree
lecture uh the idea was that uh uh well
Teresa what one of the most important
things to computer scientists and every
year I I learned at least two new cool
things about trees and so I I so I could
just talk every every December I could
talk about the coolest thing I learned
about trees that year and that went on
for more than 20 years now I I still
learn cool things about trees every year
but they're getting harder and harder to
explain to a general audience so so so
so starting about about you know five or
six years ago we just changed it to the
Christmas lecture but but this year it's
it it's again a Christmas tree lecture
because because I got you know last year
uh when I was putting the final touches
on on this this book uh volume 4B of the
art of computer programming can hey see
that
I I I learned something that I said oh
yeah this is going to be a great lecture
and so I'm going to have fun fun tonight
uh I mean from a lecturer's point of
view the uh it's always best when you
have something that you love to talk
about so um uh now speaking of uh
Christmas uh by the way this book makes
an excellent present and uh so so you
know if if somebody
doesn't know what to give you uh as a
gift uh why not try try suggesting this
one uh and and another thing uh I have a
tradition uh
of of giving away books at this lecture
every year so if you look in front on
the floor there's a they're quite a few
books actually there's there's three
times as many books this year because uh
we've had two more years to accumulate
what happens is that uh my books keep
coming out you know in in new editions
and every printing is a little bit
different and I have to check to see
whether they followed it up again
um and and also I get uh books are
translated and and uh uh I only need one
copy of a translation so what they send
me to and so on so I have extra spare
copies of books uh and they're sitting
here but they I have two rules about
these books uh the first rule is only
one per person
and the second rule is uh you have to
wait until the end of the end of the
lecture in order in order to touch them
uh I want you know somebody to to stay
for the whole thing now um
I'm gonna I'm gonna sit down now and uh
and most of it is going to be uh
about these these three topics uh that
are announced Twin Trees bacter
permutation and floor plan and so we
start with number one is Twin Trees
uh
you can't see the top
whoops
I can't either
um
all right
now uh
this is this an idea goes to um
I got the two guys named look and green
bear
in uh
1996 and uh
and I have to say that it's one word uh
uh in 1996 they actually cut they called
it Twin Trees uh with the space between
it and uh but then it turned out that
that that two other guys came up with a
completely different Concept in 1993
that was called uh Twin Trees and so in
they wrote These Guys wrote another
paper in 1996 in 1998 and and uh called
it twin binary trees well I think you
know that that I like to make it just
one word so I'm so I'm calling it twin
tree uh and and the topic is in volume
Four B uh in in in in two main exercises
there's what one on page 27 about Baxter
permutations and there's this one on
page 172 and if you if if I zoom in here
on this you can see that it actually
uh talks about where do we can you see
wait a minute here we go I got floor
floor plans but I also have twin tree
okay but here you see I
I still spell it with two words there uh
and the third printing is going to
change that uh
what are they so so like
well you might uh you might guess that
that they're they're trees
it's a pair of binary trees uh a binary
tree is a tree in which every node has
either no children or well heck it has
potentially two children a left child
and a right child
um
and and both of them uh uh
have nodes
one through n
um when you look at the tree in
symmetric order
and I'll tell you what symmetric order
is it it it
in a minute then and the easiest thing
is for me to just give you an example of
a a of a twin tree
um
because because a twin tree is a pair of
binary trees
um and so uh well it's Christmas time so
I'm going to draw the first one uh in
green
and uh it so so I have a node here
number four and then then here's two and
here's one three
uh six
five this is going to be this is going
to be a binary tree with eight nodes in
it
um
and uh
symmetric order
uh
what this is in symmetric order
symmetric quarter you you you take the
left subtree first and do it in
symmetric order then you take the root
then you do the right subtree and
symmetric order so so it's just reading
it from left to right it goes one two
three four five six seven eight
and and uh and and then uh
uh well there's two of them so he to the
other one is this five eight
seven
six I gotta do something over here let's
go all the way to one
uh three two four
so this is an example of a twin tree
data structure
and uh
the the
important concept is that node K has a
it has a right child let's say
in exactly one of the two trees
and
and the same thing for a left child
in exactly one of the trees so uh this
is this is when K is uh between one and
N but not equal n and this is when K is
between 1 and N but not equal to one
because it won't always uh one never has
a left child one is the first thing in
symmetric order so you can't have a
lecture well now uh so so let's let's
let me just show the left left and right
children here so
um
let's see I
assume that a little bit so if if I if I
look at one two three four five six
seven eight and and I write down there
uh the the left
and right
children
um
uh this is going to be left and it's
going to be right and and uh the root of
the tree is four
but then the children of four are two
and six left
okay children of two are one and three
uh children of six or five and seven
and it turned the seven uh is eight has
a seven has a right child
you know if I go to uh
the red tree it its root is five it's
got the left
um one and right is eight uh eight it
has left to seven seven has left to six
you know one has right of three three
two four okay so here here you see that
uh this is you know inside a computer I
I can share the red and the green stuff
uh as long as I have a way to tell which
is red and which is green they don't
interfere with each other exactly you
know k equals four that yeah
far is going to have a right child in
one of the trees and and uh but not but
but not in two so not going to be any
clashes all right so uh now you might
think that this is this is a really uh
unusual uh uh construction I mean you
know here we have
um
maybe you have to to search until you
find such a magical thing that has this
that has this great property but in fact
there are more than ten thousand uh Twin
Trees of order eight and in order to
verify that I'm gonna I'll just let's
just generate a random one uh right now
so
um
uh I I I'm going to need the help of the
people in in the in the front row uh so
I'm gonna I have a random permutation
um
and uh
and actually uh uh uh
okay so so I'm going to ask you do
there's going to be a two in here it's
going to be either on the right or the
left of one uh which should I what
should I do
to the right I just wonder if you were
conservative or liberally
okay so all right now uh
three has to go in here somewhere that
you can be at the left or in the middle
or the right which which should I do
could you repeat the question you want
the what
I I I I'm sorry I didn't just say middle
left or right middle
okay I shouldn't have said anything
about conservative and stuff like that
okay no
number four there's four places to put
it uh what do you think uh for it's on
the right okay now uh this is looking
random enough I'm going to ask Percy for
the next one uh because he's between one
and three between one and three okay
now we got three more to go so uh
uh
right again all right and
are you ready to the left of one until
we have extreme
extremists here
now I'm gonna I'm gonna ask uh
now I'm gonna I'm gonna show you uh one
of my favorite algorithms of all time
you know for more than 50 years is the
out is the algorithm called binary tree
insertion and and you take a permutation
and you uh
uh uh and and you write down the first
element and can you put that in the root
then you then you look at the next one
and if it's less than uh that then the
root you go to the left so the one goes
here uh uh
the next one is five well five is also
less than seven but but it's bigger than
one you know so three is less than seven
it's going to go in this uh left subtree
somewhere it's bigger than one less than
five so three comes in here uh two equal
two wow one it's it's uh
going like this eight here we go
and four so eight seven is less than
seven oh it's less than five so here
here's four and six like it's gonna it's
gonna stick in here all right so uh it
in my uh in my uh
well let me do the red ones though
because I so anyway you you can get any
binary tree you know from some
permutation but now let's take the same
permutation do it right to left so we so
we put the six here and then uh then we
insert the four so the four has to go
left of the six and then the eight uh
has to go to the right and the two has
to go to the left to three is less than
six is less than four uh five is is less
than six bigger than four uh one called
sticks all the way here and seven is
going to be here okay so now we got this
uh this thing and I'm I'm hoping I did
it right because it's supposed to give
us a twin tree
so it's one two three
four five six seven eight forget this
and seven is the root here seven has one
and
eight
um
one has five to the right five is three
and six three has two and four
um
and uh six uh is the root of this guy
and it's got four and eight
looking good so far
four has two and three and two has one
um
two has three sorry four has two and
five
yeah
so and of course these are all okay so
so now uh it worked so so we get lots
and lots of any permutation is going to
give you a a twin tree but there's going
to be you know a lot of times
two different permutations are going to
give you the same the same twin tree and
we'll have to we'll have to worry about
that but but why does it always work
well that uh the rule the reason is that
lfk
is uh is empty if and only if
uh K minus 1 was inserted into this into
this uh this thing back before k
you see why this is I mean let's take
let's take uh 4 for example so so if if
if if if if three came before four then
I'm I couldn't possibly have a left
child on four because because you know
four would have to be somehow uh they're
nothing between three and four okay you
would have to go so so uh and this was
the same but with K plus one
inserted before so so uh uh in in uh
so if if we reverse the permutation K
minus one is going to go the other on
the other side and and so it it it can't
they can't both be ill right they can't
both be R and and there's no room they
have to fill up also because because
there's just enough there's enough total
room uh and and by the way this is also
if I plug in K plus 1 for K here this is
also uh the same as saying RK minus one
is unequal to uh now and this one is
saying L of
K plus 1 is unequal now so so if you
look at any of these diagrams and you
look at at the things that are
diagonally opposite there's always going
to be you know this is green red red
green
red red green green red red green this
was two this was too uh uniform but but
that all you know that always happens
that you have one of them is green and
one of them is ready if I if I look at
it and thought okay so now this is
something you know uh this transversion
algorithm has been something that I that
I was playing with through the mid from
the middle 60s and I always and I've
used it in a zillion computer program
but I never it took 50 years before I uh
before I understood that it also gave me
Twin Trees at the same time
all right now my plan is to I'm talking
about three things Twin Trees back to
permutations and floor plan and so I'm
going to tell you up you know about each
of each of the three uh at first and and
they they're going to set and in fact
the arrow is completely different but by
completely different groups of people
they didn't know
what they were yeah they didn't know
about each other at first and uh and
then I'm going to explain why there's
amazing connection between all all these
three things so next then is um
Bachelor permutation
and and this is Glenn Baxter 1964.
and he was studying uh
continuous functions uh fixed points of
continuous functions but it during the
course of his study he he came up with
some permutations that that had peculiar
properties and the more he looked at
them and other people started looking at
him uh uh the more properties they were
discovering I I think I first heard
about Baxter permutations when John
Colorado gave a lecture to the math
department in early 70s
um so what are they uh well um
uh we we have a permutation of the of
the numbers uh one to n
uh
um you know of of the numbers one to n
ah and uh and then I can I take the
inverse permutation
um
uh so so Q uh the idea is uh uh that the
inverse permutation
tells you like qk
um
equals L if and only if PL equals K it
tells uh it tells me where does K appear
in the permutation uh and uh so so you
know inside a computer if we if we want
to uh if somebody tells us what p is uh
we quickly uh we quickly compute it by
saying Q of P of L
equals l
you know for all L
you're given p and then you immediately
can calculate Q inside uh so so anyway
let's do it for this random permutation
that we came up with a minute ago so
that was five
seven one five three
two eight four six
uh and uh that's Peep
and so Q is uh well one appear input
position two
um so one okay let's let's do the seven
so seven I get a one one gets a two five
gets a three uh three gets a four
two gets a five eight gets a six four
gets a seven and eight gets uh no what
did I do wrong six gets an eight
that's true six get
six gets an eight eight and six are
switched okay that's that's fine so um
I got I told her what permutations if I
haven't told you what Baxter
permutations are so so they're they're
Baxter permutation has no bad cases
no bad configurations uh uh where where
the first kind of a bad configuration
is uh it is
formally I says qk is less than l p l is
less it is greater than k p l plus one
this is this looks very scary but I'm
going to explain it why it's actually
not scary at all but but you look it up
in Wikipedia and it'll tell you this
definition and then there's a second
case of which is bad and that is is q k
plus one less than l
uh P L S and K B L plus one
is greater than K so and q k is greater
than L now um
now so uh
you got a question yeah
it might generate Q again
how did I generate Q yeah I I I uh L
equals one up to n so so so I looked at
P1 and it's equal to seven so I said Q7
equal to one
guy all right yeah thanks for asking yes
but please interrupt if I could
so so
um you know I said Pete I I said q1
equal to 2 Q 5 equal to three
Q60 now um but but qk less than L
says that uh uh uh and and Q K plus 1 is
greater than else you know so so here's
let's say PL and pl plus one are sitting
here uh then q k is
k k is some K is somewhere off on the
left K plus one is somewhere off on the
right uh if I'm looking at positions L
and L plus one of this of this
permutation uh and uh but here uh K plus
q k plus one is less than L that means K
plus one is appearing here and K is
appearing on this side but now PL is
some number that's bigger than k
and pl plus one is some number less than
K and so so
and this would be this is a less than
candidate so so if if we consider a
particular number K take you know this
has to this has to work for
for any any k l uh uh I I don't want any
I don't want to have any any Badness
here uh uh it it says that uh we can
take we can take for a fixed number okay
let's say k equals four uh the numbers
that are that are bigger than four let's
call Big and and the numbers that are
less than four let's call small it says
I can't have a big followed by a small
as L varies that means that means I have
a big one followed by a small between K
and K plus 1. if if K appears before K
so if four appears before 5 I can't have
a yeah I I I can't have a a big guy and
then a small guy and then and and uh so
so the um uh uh the other the other case
is similar if if I have K plus one uh
occurring uh before k then I look at all
the numbers between the two and I can't
have a small Follow by a big
so so the uh the now sort of the
smallest possible uh
non-baxter permutation is uh is actually
one of the most famous uh
permutations that are of all is three
one four two
um
you see take take k equal to two uh and
so so one is is small and four is Big so
I have you know I I have a a small
followed by a big here
are you with me now why is this such a
famous permutation well I call it the pi
mutation because uh you get you know
everybody knows that Pi is 3.142 and and
but but but
for years uh I've been uh working with
permutations and and I I've done
countless problems where I have a
conjecture about the way permutations
work and if the conjecture is false it
almost always fails at the pi mutation
so
there's something about this that makes
it uh that makes it uh uh important so
the other thing is uh the inverse of the
of the pi mutation which is which is
also the left to right uh reversal of it
uh that feels that filled the first case
here here two occurs before three so and
we have a big number uh uh followed by a
little number okay so so the
if n equals 4 these are the only two
non-baxter permutations and there's 24
you know four factorial is 24 so so
there's 24 so n equals four
um uh
then we have 22 Baxter permutations and
for three two and one it uh they all
they're all fine and and we get to 5 for
92 out of 120 and 6 was 422 of 7 was 20
74 and 8 is
Ten Thousand Seven fifty four now
um
eight factorial is uh about forty
thousand so we got a chance of something
like uh one in four that this random
permutation that you guys came up with
is is Baxter how are we going to check
to see whether seven one five three two
eight four six is Baxter
is it bad or not well we just have to
check K and K plus 1 and see what's big
and small between so so one and two is
never a problem because everything is
there's not there's no small numbers
between one and
nothing less than one so but so so what
one and two more but two and three
there's nothing between them between
three and four though uh we've got uh
you know two is uh
um is small and eight is big and that
that's that's that's bad you know it it
it's like three one four two no it's not
no no this is fine
this was fine this was three followed by
four so no problem four or five uh now
we've got a not now we've got to have uh
uh two and three are small and eight is
Big so that's no good uh so so here's a
counter example where K is four K plus
one and we have a smaller a small
followed by large that's the uh
so uh well it's not a back to
permutation but uh
we could go on five to six uh uh it it
seems uh the small guys are two and two
three four and the biggest eight so
there's a mixture of small and large so
so it's failing on that one too so this
is yeah okay uh but anyway uh
uh a lot of permutation to our Baxter as
as you can see from these counts and uh
and uh it's not too hard to check a
given one by just you know just by going
hopping from one to two to three to four
if I eat for each each time you hop I
you look at the things between that you
and you see if the bad bad and and
little guys in uh uh uh are in the right
order or not
um now um
uh one thing we can see uh in order in
order to get an idea is if if if I have
a baxter permutation I can take it I can
flip it left to right and I get another
bacter permutation uh well the reason is
sort of that rule this the first rule
slips into the second row
uh another another thing is I I can take
a if I have a box of permutation and I
take its inverse uh again I get a baxter
permutation because we just we sort of
Switched the q's and P's around so so uh
uh uh and uh but but
you can also put one next to each other
so suppose I have a a a baxter
fermentation of one to one to M here
this is some Baxter permutation and here
I have another
bacter permutation of M plus 1 through
n so so these are our numbers one to m
in some order but they but they qualify
as Baxter and here uh it's the same
thing except I added M to m2h um so I
got a you know I took another box of
permutation but promoted every number
make it make it bigger bigger than them
uh uh this is going to be this is going
to be fine because why because I go from
one to two to three to four or and so on
and I don't get any bad cases here uh
and and then I jump from M to n plus one
look well all of this all of the small
guys are going to be are all going to
come
first and the big guys think this later
between M and M plus one and then then
once I'm up up into this half and again
I could jump in plus two and so on and I
never get any bad situations again so so
this is a back I get a box of
permutation by sort of uh juxtaposing I
could also do it this way I could put
the I could put the M plus one to n at
the left and one to M at the right and
again uh then he'll jump around in there
but it'll it it'll it'll work out fine
so so anyway you can see why that why
there's a variety of bacter permutations
and now it's time for topic three
topic three is floor plan
and this is something
that is a decomposition
of rectangle into rectangle
into sub-rect angles Okay so
um and now um
uh
I
uh
I guess I I might as well give you an
example so um
right off
I'll take this rectangle here
and I'm going to um
subdivide it
um
I'll keep give you a minute
to raise some coordinates here V3 V4 V5
and h0 not H1 H2 H3 H4
h5h6 so so this is a five by six uh grid
and I'm and I'm going to divide it into
into sub rectangles and I've
this one goes down to H3
and then I'm going to put one here
and I can carry this over on V3
okay
um
I I want to
um I I could have prepared a slide here
but but I didn't want to go too fast to
see so G and then
okay so here
not so I'm going to call this uh ABC the
the rec the sub rectangles I call rooms
so I got 10 rooms here c d e f
g h i j
um and the and the uh the line segments
that that are the um so okay so
rectangle is a room
and the and the segments
it's called a bound so
every room uh
has four segments that got bounded on
the top left right bottom
um and and so I've got in this case I've
got a segment h0 I've got H1 H2 h3h4
H5 and H6 and I've got I I've got
vertical segments also I cook I used a v
until I remember it's vertical this is
this is actually supposed to be one
straight line and and so uh
uh
that this uh
as as I you can imagine
concept very important in in layout of
vlsi uh you know making silicon chips uh
because uh because the uh the rooms
correspond to uh modules or or Gates and
of the circuit and the and the bounds
correspond to channel
um
so uh where uh uh electrical think uh
so so now the uh
I I should I should I should mention
that in this decomposition of rectangles
uh I I I I
we always have have have the tatami
condition which means that no no four
rectangles uh have a heck have the same
Corner Point uh
in Japan uh uh they have this what this
this wonderful uh Angel custom of of of
covering their floor with the Tommy mats
and uh and and uh the
uh the rule is uh you don't have ever a
situation where you know something like
uh
like this would be bad okay
because because
there are four
this corner you know we have four to
tell him about touching the same point
so so so anyway uh
that's a kind of a degenerate thing and
uh
now the uh
uh
the interesting thing the the important
thing is is uh when we
when we discuss
uh
what does it mean for two different
floor plans to be the same because
because it doesn't equivalence
there's an equivalence between floor
plans which means that it's going to
give you the same circuit for example if
you make a chip out of it so so if uh so
I so I I can I can actually uh draw that
exact same same floor plan
but but it looked it looked different if
I if I put the uh if I put the bounds in
different orders so here I'm going to do
v0 V2 V1
V3 V4 V5 and and in the horizontal I'm
going to go h0 H1
H3 H5 h
2
h4h6 and I'm going to I'm going to draw
the exact same uh floor plan so a a went
from a from H 0 to H3 and V 0 to V1 so
it's going to be h0 to H3 and B 0 to B1
so this is going to be a now B goes uh
across
on H1 C is it is between V1 and V
V1 and V3 which is just this little not
this little thing here
um so C is between H1 and H3
G goes uh
um h
1 to H2 so so G is now
the I could go in here
um
okay
and so on so so
I'm going to get d
between H3 and H5
um and then e is down here
f is this big guy
h
J and I claim that that this is the same
diagram because it because each
rectangle has the same boundaries
um now so so uh
uh you need some notation for this so I
so I I'll say for example v0
right arrow a V1 this means that V 0 is
at the left of a and V1 is at the right
of a all right
and uh H 0
is above a and and above H3
and so uh I've got 10 rooms here and and
so I'm going to you know there's
40 different relations between these
things but the but the idea that two two
floor plans are
equivalent if if they have the same
relations if there's a one-to-one
correspondence that between the rooms
like the two room a course here of
course by the room a here and and the
bounds so bound age zero corresponds to
h0 H1 corresponding you know H3 uh H2
got here and and so all of these
relations are are preserved between
these uh between these two things
um the the I put the labels on just so
you can see what what matches between
the two but but you know I I I could I
could have made labels blank and I would
say this floor plan is equivalent to
this floor plan because there's a
one-to-one correspondence between the
the rooms and the balance
all right now
um
uh you got questions on this
so if you represented the two floors and
please speak very loudly I forgot to
wear my hearing yeah so if you
represented the two girlfriends as
graphs would they look the exact same
I represent as graphs then what yes so
the rooms are notes and then if they
share a bound it's an edge so with the
graphs be isomorphic
the the graphs are
well if if you label the yeah but you
have you have to consider that that the
different kind of arcs the the
horizontal Arc and the vertical Arc into
so so the graphs are are isomorphic uh
but but the but you have to distinguish
a horizontal if I didn't distinguish
horizontal from vertical that then then
it would be a different concept
okay now uh but but uh the uh but uh you
talked about representation and of
course one of the things we want to do
is represent this in a computer in some
way and we'd like to have a
representation that that equivalent
floor plans have the look the same
inside the computer or you know easy
easy to tell that this one
equals that one so um
so now I want to explain to you how we
can get a a canonical form that I can
that I can that I can take any floor
plan and I can and I can draw
I can draw it in a certain way so that
both of these would would turn out to be
to have the same result so there are 10
rooms and and for this canonical form
I'm going to use uh I'm going to use a
this kind of paper and I'm going to give
myself
10 by 10 area to work with the one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
uh so that you can see what I'm doing I
guess I got
two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
um okay so so I'm gonna I'm gonna uh
redraw this floor plan in a canonical
way that both of these are
are going to are going to end up the
same so I might as well just use this
one uh to start with and and uh
no you you notice that inside uh in
inside a floor plan
um
I said we got the tatomy condition so we
so there's only four kinds of Junctions
that we can have a junction could look
like this it can look like this or it
can look like this or it can look like
that but we
at the corners we only have two but but
otherwise these are all all all the
chunks are saying and so I I I start at
the upper left hand corner and and I put
uh
put it here and then I look at the lower
at the lower part of that room
and uh
and and I and I see that uh it it ends
it ends with a upside down T Junction
for a so it's up in the lower right hand
corner it's an a which means that uh uh
the boundary here uh
the the right bound is is this vertical
bound V1 and uh
and then there's
there's going to be a neighbor on the
other side
um now um
and and and the fundamental idea it uh
it is called flattening
um and so I'm going to take I'm going to
take a here and I'm going to flatten it
by by
moving this bound all the way to the
left from smashing a so that so as the
width has gone down to zero and then
eight and so so so this being this line
is going to extend over uh
it's it's going to um
yeah
I'm not going to redraw the whole thing
but after I flattened a b is going to
extend all the way to the right to the
left and and C is going to extend all
the way to that but D and F and all
these other guys are
are are still are still going to be with
the way they were so I would just I
smash a but by moving it all here now
I've got nine rooms left
and and I'm and uh I then I I'm going to
find a canonical form of these nine
rooms and later on put put a back in
again
so uh in a way uh that means I want to
um
well later on I'm going to put I'm going
to put a line here and and uh
and what I'm doing is I'm I I I I I I'm
I'm flattening a so and sort of setting
V1 to v0 because V1 has moved all moved
over to v0
so I'm going to call this V1 here
this is v0
um now
so now I'm left with B
and what kind of a junction is is that
the other at the other side of B well B
has the other has this kind of a
junction
it's upper right hand corner and and so
I'm going to flatten B upwards instead
of instead of left right
and and flattening B upwards is easy in
this case because I just remove it from
the diagram so I'm going to have B
flattened here
um
and and uh and uh I'm going to change
H1 to h0 uh because I'm moving H1 up
flattening our B and I'm going to put a
line below it B because uh
later on after I get the canonical form
I'm going to put B back in again on
flattening the car okay well uh c c also
has a a junction like this after it and
and it turns out H3
let's put h
H1 here and H
uh
3 is going to go here
but I'm no it's going to go here excuse
me
that I'm only going I'm not going to put
any H here I'm going to put H here and C
is here with uh H3 goes to sort of H1
when I flatten C
and now
now what does this look like after I
flattened C well
um
uh
dnf have moved up so so now the
uh
the current state is I got D sitting
here and F
and and G
um
and and and D is um
here's another one that has has the same
business here so H5 is going to
go to H3 and so I'm going to put D here
and H5 is going to be underneath it
um at this point we get a break in the
action and E
um
is um you after after I slid this up
then he came up here
and E goes all the way down to the
bottom and it has
the upside down T Junction again and so
that's going to be a v
2 to V1
so I put an e here and I put a V and I
put a line to the right like I did with
the A and I put V2 over here
so anyway this is this is a systematic
construction and if you if you if if I
were doing that on not on this diagram
but I was doing it on this diagram it I
would be doing exactly the same thing
because they're isomorphic according to
according to the right bound of a uh the
same Junctions are there and I just you
know
move everything up so so
um what's going to happen is uh uh it uh
I'm going to get ghij uh and that's
that's uh
I might as well write the whole thing
down because this is going on the
internet
um
she
g h
I
I don't pay for errors in Islam
and Jay has has actually a a a a corner
but but this is going to say V3 to V2
um so f is going to be here I'm going to
B3
and then um
the uh this was going to be an H
h v
and this is going to be both H and V
so this will say a
h two
H five
and this is going to be H2 here
and H
I'm going to get H
4 here
and I is on the right I'm going to get a
V for and here I'm going to get V5 and V
and H
six okay so so this is V5 this is V6 H5
and this is H shot
four
uh
uh now so
now I've like now I've got right now I
know where the bounds are in this thing
and so now I just have to draw the uh I
I have to draw the the the diagram so so
I know that a goes from V 0 to V1 in in
one dimension Direction and and H 0 to
H3 in the other direction so so a is now
um
here and B is going to take over this
whole Space
and so on and so on okay well I've I
I've got it um
I've got it
here
so that's what I just constructed by
um and this is this is actually a
conical form for this uh
for that floor plan now
um
but we can do the same thing
we can oh by the way it's not a
coincidence that that it came out in
alphabetical order ABCD
but I had to choose some arbitrary names
for these rooms and so I I so that's the
way I picked them I could I could have
called it I couldn't call them anything
uh but but I chose to put them in you
know so that that this one uh you know
take any floor plan
um and and convert conical form look at
the diagonal and and and name the rooms
uh one in or or alphabetically whichever
you want
now but that same that same procedure
that we just used for canonical form uh
I I could make another canonical form
where interchange bottom and top so
instead of starting at the at the upper
left corner I could start at the lower
left corner and instead of looking at uh
at the junction here I could look at the
junction up opposite and so if if we do
that same procedure again but but we go
uh but but we go bottom to top but
instead of top to bottom then we get
this pattern which is which is
it's the same um it hits that same floor
plan but it's and it's canonical but
it's it it's the anti-canonical form of
The Ant And so so we got two canonical
form one one has a diagonal which which
goes strictly increasing order and the
other is um uh the anti-diagonal
uh both of them are permutation and and
uh well now it's time to to say well why
uh what does this have to do with uh
Twin Trees and and Baxter permutation
well uh
the second answer is the easiest to say
this is a baxter permutation uh you know
e to D
and uh
and it it's if and only if in other
words every every floor plan uh uh when
you put it into canonical form
with the diagonal of one and the
anti-diagonal permutation of one and
that permutation is the Baxter
permutation and every Baxter permutation
is gives you a floor plan so the number
of floor plans with four rooms is 22.
the the number of accidents you know and
and
and uh
uh
the connection with Twin Trees is even
it it is even nicer
um and so I uh uh let's take a look at
at the um
what what Twin Trees we we get from this
from this permutation
um
so uh the green the green tree starts
with e
and then then come D so that goes here
then comes F which goes here then comes
a
and comes C less than E equals here I is
bigger than e it's bigger than f
H is less than I
uh J is bigger than I
G is bigger than F less than h
B is um
down here
and do the other in the other order we
get the uh we get the twin of the tree
and that's B uh and G comes over here
Jay
h
I
C here
a
f
f is here
um D that's what the
D is a big left Century okay d e looks
like this looks like it got this okay
now
Twin Trees and I've
um
I I
did this with my computer so I I'd be
sure I get it right
um so so here are the here are the Twin
Trees that correspond to that
permutation to that that permutation
which I claim is a baxter presentation
oh
and here we we start to see the uh
that I put dots around it looked at look
at efij
well it turns out efij
is um
exactly the rooms that are at the bottom
of this diagram
it's the e-f-i-j
and so they call that H6
these are the things just above age six
okay uh D is the is what's just above H5
what's just above age three A and C here
we go H3 is here
um what about H4 that's just H that's
just H4 uh G is is H2 uh B is H1 so so
um uh these these families that we see
in the in the Twin tree are exactly uh
what goes next to a bound these are the
you know H is a channel these are the
modules that touch that touch that
channel what can you move the page down
a little can I move the what the page
down
so we can't see the top again
oh okay
all right I have another idea let me go
to uh
um
let me go to volume four but okay anyway
here we got the picture but if I go to
the answer to exercise 372
[Music]
um
uh
no I I guess we can't see them both at
the same time but anyway this picture uh
is it is is in the book right okay so so
uh
yes so I zoom out and we and we and we
and we can see the on the whole guy
you know and
and uh
okay so so now as you can imagine that
that the the the the the uh like bgj
these are the guys touching the right
thing uh those are that those are in
this tree okay
the guys
less than V5 the guys who are less than
V4 that's that's just I
think bgj
H H and I H and I think so this is the
this is V5 this is V4
um and and so on uh the V3 all the v's
appear here but now on this side I got G
and C well what's that that's below H1
so so you know A and A and B are the
things below h0 so so the idea the idea
is uh for each each of the bounds uh you
know in in your circuit you want to know
what what are the modules touching that
that channel on top and touching the
channel underneath and they occur in the
Twin tree
as you know a sequence of left links or
right links
um so just a beautiful representation
inside the computer for the floor plan
no no I I've got uh some
I put some programs online uh
because the
the this amounts to a a what you know a
wonderful
Trio of of
byjections one-to-one correspondences
between floor plans uh Twin Trees and
Baxter permutation because it because uh
uh
um
you give me a back to permutation I can
tell you what the floor plan is you give
me a floor plan I can tell you what the
Twin Trees are you give me a twin tree I
can tell you what what's the unique
Vector permutation that that generates
it and those are all and all of those
algorithms are linear time they you know
the length of the permutation uh it they
all take order n steps
to go from one to uh uh to the next in
the sequence and I've got a a sequence
of computer programs online uh that that
implement this and and
I forgot to bring the programs with
copies of the programs with me but but
these are are literate programs which
means that uh you know
intended to be read by by people
and and uh let me zoom in here uh to uh
so you can see
a sample run of the program
um I I but by the way it's just
yeah thanks for focusing uh the
I I mean I I it would if somebody's
interested they could take my programs
and uh you know convert it into an app
which will make all of this a wonderful
graphic interface and and flattened
floor plans and you know enjoy yourself
but anyway this is this is what what my
program gives you so I type in a a
permutation and this happens to be the
permutation of the example but the
letters are converted to numbers so this
is e d
f a c and so on J is for 10. uh and and
so this was the input and and the output
comes out and says well room number one
goes from at the left is why I I I guess
this is top bottom left right top bottom
left right for each room and and so it
cranks out the floor plan
um
for that corresponds to this Baxter
permutation and if you give it a
permutation that's not Baxter it it uh
sneers at you and it's too bad
you lose it's not back
now I I can feed this floor plan
to another program called floor plan to
Twin tree
and
um
and took this was the input
so it read the specs for 10 rooms and
seven horizontal bounds six critical
bounds and so here's the Twin Trees that
comes out so the first tree is rooted at
five and and it says the five goes four
at the left six to the right so these
are the left and right links
um in in the tree
uh and uh and then I have another form
of this floor plan the twin tree What's
called the TT form which which has this
which produces output in another Form
This is a form uh where you first show
The Roots and then you give the uh the
left and right
for the two different trees uh this this
was the form that's the input to my
third program which is called twin tree
to Baxter and if I if I if so I feed
this to and feed this one and then I
feed that the twin tree Baxter I get
back uh of course the one I started with
uh so so those programs are are all
online on my home page and uh uh uh
I I have a
I I guess I I should say a couple of
things about it um
before I finish but I'm almost done uh
the first thing is this Baxter to floor
plan uh the ideas in there are due to
Ackerman
and pincher in 2006
and if you look at the at the code for
this this algorithm I I mentioned I
wrote this when I was learning it but
like this algorithm is almost too good
to be true
so I I recommend reading the algorithm
not just using them the floor plan to
Twin tree is is due to people named the
owl sorry Yao Chen
King and Graham
and by the way this is
our friend Ron Graham
and this is 2003
and the program has several phases and
one of them is called the cool phase and
again it's a okay and and the twin tree
to Baxter is an algorithm that's based
on the guys who invented Twin Trees to
Luke and quiver 1996.
hey so so uh and and this uh
we get to a part of that program which
is called a stunning construction
which is in Lemma 4 of their paper so so
anyway these these algorithms I I
believe are are fun to read the final
thing I want to explain is that explains
uh the whole
um
uh the
the main connection there is uh I'm
going to draw just uh
four little diagrams for junction I have
a t Junction
this Junction
this Junction
in this Junction
and
I can say I suppose I have a room r
in this position
in the floor plan
then
elevar is here
aravar is here
in other words the right Branch below
are uh and um
green elevar is here
and green arvar is here so so this is
the the uh uh the magic of the amazing
connection between all of these things
uh uh here we have the links of the Twin
Trees here we have the Junctions in the
floor plan
all right well um I'm I'm 10 minutes
over uh I was expecting to be 20 minutes
over so I'm glad I didn't I thought so
uh
thanks for listening and I got I'm ready
for questions
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh does it work all right okay
okay
[Music]
so if I recall correct
still a twin
mutation when we were first building
like a twin tree from a poo mutation so
is it correct to say that if we had a